That's why we should have taken
more consideration to the halation caused by collective action and panic.
[Music]
Why are you here? Why are you here to help? What are you doing?
You're really doing something wrong. Why did you go to such lengths?  Is
n't that enough?
Everyone
wants to eat as much as they can when they're hungry. If they
meet a cute girl, they want to be friends. If
someone asks for help right in front of them, they want to
be a hero. They needed a
reason for
that.  It's not the end. I
came here and just did what I wanted to do. It's
probably a good strategy. I
came here without thinking, but if I keep going like this, I won't be able to tell. It's
so stupid that even I can't believe it,
but I'll
give it a try.
[Music]
After all, Akira-kun isn't here. Earn time